[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Frances Foster I'm Constance in
kissimmee and this is the show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people our guest today is an
Australian filmmaker Mike Nina welcome
to trigonometry hey you know it's good
to have you on the show man thank thanks
for coming on we met you are about a
year ago now I think it was exactly a
year ago out there long okay yeah and
we've been very keen to talk to you
since and really one of the reasons we
would particularly keen to talk to you
sir James Lindsay a mutual friend sent
us your film did you okay yeah it was
like you must watch this and we both did
and felt that it was really really
incredible so he kind of made it extra
special for us to chat with you but for
anyone who hasn't seen the film who
doesn't know who you I just give us a
little bit of a background as who are
you how are you where you are what has
been your journey through life okay I'm
an Australian filmmaker and I'm
interested in the Internet and what's
that dude what's that doing to us as
humans and activism I guess the digital
part of activism that we're seeing a lot
of and yeah I've made several films now
in that area I guess how we came to meet
at some point was I started looking into
activism a strange kind of activism kind
of destructive in my opinion activism it
wasn't doing what it said on the box I
started looking at that in here in
Australia and I started hanging out with
in activist circles and and monitoring
activists on on social media and I
followed a lot of their concepts and
language to the Academy it seemed like
they were there was an intellectual
engine underneath a lot of the things
that were talking about and from there I
guess that meant I spoke to a lot of
academics and I stumbled into what could
be considered a an academic undergrad
I guess with a lot of people who were
concerned about certain fields in
cultural studies and they weren't I mean
they would open up to me behind the
scenes but they were very concerned
about speaking publicly about this kind
of stuff so I had a lot of experiences
where I'd meet academics and we'd be in
their office and they would lock the
door and we'd speak in hushed tones or
we'd start email threads that would
start on there
vii twice actually it started on their
academic their official academic inbox
professor so-and-so at beacon dot edu
dot u and then they would take it
halfway when we got into the
nitty-gritty they would take it to their
personal accounts and this started
happening I thought that was it was very
strange that academics wouldn't feel
open about talking about something like
that particularly because they were so
passionate about it
and that eventually may led me to cross
paths with Helen Park Burroughs James
Lindsay and Peter Bergeron who were just
about to take part in this academic hope
scandal that later became known as the
grievance study scandal and I guess I've
been making a films in this area it's
like a rabbit hole that keeps on opening
up further and further into new and
interesting things and interesting
people I guess we met in London last
year as a result of this and I seem to
be heading into some strange kind of
reluctant pundit role find myself on
stages and being invited on things like
this it's not exactly what I want to be
where I am right now well that's the
first time he gets to be on the show I
just kind of want to hide away and make
films you know like do it in my own time
and ensuring something and maybe do a
Q&A it's quite strange to be caught up
in this political mess and
and be talking about these things and
why would these academics care Mike um
well there's there's many reasons I mean
ye are a lot of people scared to say
things that they're concerned about
right now I think that these particular
fields in cultural studies they have
connections to diversity boards and
things like that and it's it's it's got
quite a product they what would you call
it like a hushing fact an Intimidator
it's intimidating kind of kind of
entities within the university that make
people feel weird about saying things
openly and it's it's I mean it's the
same in arts and to entertainment you
guys would experience that over there
there's certain things that you just
don't talk about and if you talk about
that publicly then it's not like anyone
will tell you face to face but you do
get a sense that there are whispers
around and things like that so there
that's very much taking place within
academia in in a big way and the more
I'm looking into this the more and more
that seems like that's what's going on
Mike people understand like what is it
that these academics are scared to talk
about are they people who want to
measure black people's dimples skulls or
like what is it that the people are
terrified to discuss well this forbidden
knowledge I guess there are there areas
of inquiry that people want to go into
race IQ being one of them even just
talking about biological sex you can get
into trouble there's a guy named Bruce
Keeley over in he's a colleague of Peter
big oceans who wrote something about a
case for colonialism so let's look at
some positives that took place as a
result of colonialism my close
you never said it was a good thing you
just said some there's certain parts of
it and these these guys in academia and
he got driven out of his he's profession
he got chained and there's a lot of
these kinds of stories Britain Britain
Heather from Britt Weinstein and Heather
I'm from Evergreen State College I made
a series about that I spoke to them
about it
where
that stood up to this this orthodoxy I
guess is moral orthodoxy that was
emerging within in school and a knack
and equity plan that they were trying to
put in place which overstepped the
bounds I think into his stem field so he
started talking up speaking up about
that and then you've just got to see the
series to see what happened there I
can't actually do it justice yeah having
a in conversational form but if you go
to my channel and check it out you'll
see some strange things took place and
what we're seeing in academia is people
being forced out now these people would
argue that what they're doing is good
and right and it's the morally correct
thing to do after will racism is bad
isn't it sexism is bad the more
diversity the better what are your
opinions on it Mike well it depends
they're reasonable edges of this and
then there I it's it's difficult to draw
a lines around this in pretty hardcore
postmodern sections of the Academy that
are studying quite strange things it's
it's almost like it's a fundamentalist
sect of the new left so it is it's not
it's not that simple it's it's actually
hard to speak about on in simple terms
because you have to you you go down
layers of this stuff there is a there
are surface level arguments that people
are having it's like oh yeah that that
seems perfectly reasonable but then if
you go back in the scholarship maybe one
decade or two decades or three decades
you're getting into some very strange
philosophies they've got a different
conception of how humans are put
together they have this kind of blank
slate philosophy of human human beings
that humans can be reshaped I guess
through through the discourses in the
way we speak about things and the way
the knowledge is produced and so right
now we're dealing with with we're
probably three decades into some very
very strange conceptions of reality in
humans and where we're talking about
surface level things like
[Music]
cultural appropriation and many of these
what is the basis for biological sex
it's all rooted in this 30-year old
philosophy that's that's been yeah I
guess built built over the past few
decades I might just say you know what
we're gonna do is we're gonna clip that
and Francis is gonna say well racism is
bad isn't it and then you're gonna go it
depends it depends on what your
definition of racism is right like if
you've got the traditional definition of
racism where it's where it's
discrimination based on immutable
characteristics then that is horrific
and let's let's work against that but if
you're talking about systems of power
and privilege we're waking up in the
morning and buying a coffee and putting
on some kind of hat is racism then we've
got we're gonna have to have a bigger
conversation and this this is what these
feel to doing their broader need the
concept of racism and it's it's getting
to the point where it's just it's
capturing people just going about their
everyday business and Mike what what
there'll be lots of people who would say
look this is a problem on campuses but
it doesn't affect broader society you
know it's just students being students
let's be fair students and knobs I was
in love when I was that age I think we
all were what is your argument to that
that it has no real effect on wider
culture I guess it just always seemed
obvious to me that the culture is down
downstream from the Academy our arrow
our elite classes that cultural
producers they all go through the
Academy and they learn these things and
then they come out and they produce art
they produced journalism they create the
they produce the templates for how we
think and so it's it's not it's never
really struck me as something that's
kind of off in the corner of our culture
the producing strange things it's it all
our best and brightest minds go
and they come out and then they create
culture and so we live downstream from
the Academy so whatever happens there it
will eventually happen within the
culture it will manifest in some sense I
mean you know it'll be pushback upon
from people who don't who haven't gone
through that way of thinking but it's
there it's there it's definitely there I
don't exactly know how to articulate
that but it just seems so obvious to me
I know my name it's interesting because
probably a year and a half ago now I got
this offer to do a comedy show to
university and they sent me like a
massive contract with the list of 50
things that yarn supposed to joke about
and when I turn it down and he became
quite a big story over here people
having to go of me and saying will wide
one way way you know why do you feel so
strongly about it these are just some
silly students and I was like well
they're not just some silly students
they're gonna grow up and become you
know MPs
lawyers journalists and they're going to
be shaping the world of tomorrow and I
don't wanna live and so what you was
that when we did that take place that
was literally the last few days of 2018
2018 right yeah and and you know I know
I was saying at the time that yes
slippery slope arguments don't always
necessarily accurately reflect reality
but if we allow people to censor comedy
you know whatever we're gonna start to
find that you know we start to go back
through history and erase things that
were done and and cancel shows that have
been on on TV for a long time and
question everything and it's been 18
months and look where we are now man
yeah yeah and it's it's it's a one-way
right it's when pushing back is saying
or even just hold up let's talk about
this is seen as immoral then you're on a
freight train to something very strange
and I mean anyone's picked up a history
book this kind of behavior happens and
then famines and death and genocide
happen so it's not so clear to me why
many people bring it on man bring it on
let's get on this freight train you
think it's just cowardice Mike in the
sense that I
a lot of most people are busy and
they've got busy lives and they don't
have time to delve into this stuff in
the way yeah you know you and I in
Francis do but what they do know as you
said in academia and I think it's true
everywhere else as well is if you speak
out against this stuff you will be
punished and so if you don't really know
what's going on and you're scared and
you have a reason to be scared why would
you get involved why don't you just go
yeah look all right well they keep
saying this word cultural appropriate
these two words cultural appropriation
they keep saying white privilege they
keep saying like all these things but I
don't really know I'm not an expert but
if I question the stuff I'm gonna get
fired you know my reputation is gonna be
this there's even a different population
that are in the middle of that they hear
it and it speaks to their moral
sensibilities it's it's it still speaks
to my moral sensibilities there's this
kind of care harm moral access that it's
speaking to and so you if you haven't
done your homework you would hear a lot
of this stuff and go hey this is just
some kind of extension of the civil
rights movement um but if you do your
homework and see what's underneath it
it's it's it's not at all and so I find
that a lot of people who whose moral
instincts are being spoken to and poke
poke and prod it playing apologetics for
it they're going oh well they can't mean
that they must mean and then they say
what they must mean and in in that sense
there is this cover for this really
strange radical thing that that's moving
up and so they just look at the look of
what they're actually saying abolish
police let's get rid of that they're
actually saying that they're not it's
not reform I'm down for reform I'm not
progressive but but it's not actually
what they're saying if you if you go if
you just do a little homework it's
getting so true that is so true man
because this is the point I've been
trying to make to a lot of people and on
radio and whatever like the lives of
black people matter and everybody
supports that but if you look at the
organization of black lives matter and
that their own stated goals
and what they're demanding and what
they're suggesting and their agenda and
who found it and who runs it that's a
whole different ballgame and you wants
to believe it no website I can't see so
it's quite offensive as someone who
comes from Venezuela I've got to say
abolishing the police did wonders for my
country so Francis's just said that his
mother is from Venezuela so make sure
you have a drink this is your
opportunity now I'll mention I'm from
Russia in a second when we cash in on
our city exactly we like Constantine
said we've touched on you know black
lives matter yesterday was the first day
back for Premier League football and
literally every footballer took a knee
imagine if a footballer particularly
like a white footballer just didn't I
mean that's career over isn't it he's
done Yeah right yeah I mean have we got
to this point where even saying
something like saying you don't agree
with all aspects of a political
organization means cancellation well I
suspect it's been sold quite well like
people don't look at what's what's
underneath it they're not looking at
there they're looking at the individual
arguments they're not looking at the
constellation of what's going on like if
you take a few steps back and you
realise it's not just this it's this and
this and this and this you start to
notice hang on a second there is some
kind of revolution of foot uh you know
on the individual case in the individual
case it's often very reasonable but if
you're if you're losing moving ground on
10,000 different fronts then all of a
sudden you're heading towards some kind
of revolutionary into joining a
revolutionary enterprise so it is it is
strange because I'm all my friends and
family are experiencing is from the
surface level and they're all yeah black
lives they do matter I was like yeah
yeah that's that's true I can see where
you're coming from but let's go - let's
go their website and look what they're
actually about this is quite kind of
scary
but people don't want to do that do they
that's the thing that terrifies me is
people and and again I keep saying this
in our interviews in the last few weeks
this dissent me back to echoes of what
we went through in the Soviet Union
where people knew what they were
supposed to not look at mmm and what
information they didn't for knowledge
right right and and not even so much
forbidden knowledge more like I don't
want to expose myself to this
information because then I would have to
have the wrong opinion honest you know
and that's I see so much of that flying
around at the moment you know what I
mean yeah yeah I might moving swiftly on
to your film didja lanty which we both
watch we loved I mean that was very very
interesting as well in that it was you
know talking about digital activism
which you were involved with um for
people who haven't seen the film could
you just give a brief synopsis about
what it's about and then we'll delve
into it do you like my little gesture
dude there was quite nicely I guess it's
about an experience that I had where a
racist incident took place races and
sexist incident took place on a bus and
I filmed it and I was it was 2012 was
the time when viral videos were just
started to end into the kind of public
consciousness and so I'd had
successfully a couple of our videos I
kind of knew had the Pope and problem in
a certain way you know seed them on the
back end and then and get these things
going and so I applied that to this
video to get revenge on the guys that
were being horribly racist and sexism
though they were Co dicks though that we
know doing the wrong thing and so and
they weren't just being racist and
sexist they were also being threatening
that's that yeah yeah yeah it's horrific
so what then happened was the video did
go viral and it turned into this kind of
international press
incident I think part of it was the
zeitgeist about the racism sexism that
really put an engine underneath it but
also because viral videos were only just
starting to come out and so it turned
into this really really big
international incident and my experience
of it was being on the inside of this
prints incident and then seeing how it
was communicated and how it was talked
about was very different to how I
experienced it and so I would meet
someone in the street talk to him about
it and their impressions of the incident
and everything that was going on around
it was very different and so it was it's
a very strange experience to being the
middle of a press explosion because you
get a first-hand experience of how
disconnected a meteor incident the
incident can become from the actual
reality of the event itself and so it's
the the story is it's a short
documentary and it's just it's just
about that experience and I caught up
with some of the racist he wasn't racist
he was just think violent one of that
wasn't racist he was just violent it's a
big sunny day and we're all drinking and
so yeah that's where it leads to usually
yeah a long time ago it was like 2015
and it only just recently got picked up
by Atlantic because I think it just
becomes more and more relevant as time
goes on and the internet keeps
delivering these incidents well I mean I
think you've described it factually in
terms of the storyline but I actually
think that to me that wasn't what it was
really about in the sense that to me it
was much more about your journey of
going from here's a racist incident I
filmed it how do I make this go viral -
oh [ __ ] this is now viral you know I'm
not happy with what I've done here yes
yes and it's about it's about also
having control over something you don't
have control over that you can something
that goes viral something you put
on the internet you have control of the
preconditions and that's it
so you once you let it go then it will
turn into something and it did turn into
something and turn into something quite
ugly
I felt and the conversations that were
happening around racism that it sparked
they didn't seem to make any sense to me
they were it wasn't constructive either
I didn't think it was doing any good it
was just doing it was just causing more
harm and making people pissed off and so
I was looking at that and it kind of
made me rethink the dynamics of these
kind of viral incidents and how all this
stuff worked and I guess that's why I'm
looking at what I'm looking at now
because it's it's very much it was an
insight into how strange the public
discourse is how strange and
unproductive the public discourse is
around race and that was and how the
media plays into that and how social
media plays into that and so that hasn't
launched me into this new new thing I'm
working on now and one of the things
that I found very interesting about it
was this desire and I don't know whether
it's innate in us of the desire for
revenge where you saw what happened to
these men who did let's be fair they
were awful awful but then the reaction I
would say was even worse and a desire to
destroy these men's lives was his bus
incident that took place in real life
and then there's this digital incident
they're looking hell of a lot like what
took place on the bus and so it's such a
strange thing that are kind of echoed
into this giant a mythological event
where where people the anger that was on
the bus and the thing that people were
angry about well they were just
replicating so I was just creating more
destruction and more anger and more
threats and violence and saying horrible
things about people and so yeah that's I
think a something that I noticed from
that was from that experience is that
revenge isn't constructive there's
nothing constructive about revenge no
one wins in the end and so I guess
that's the position I have now with this
new car
activism that I'm looking at it looks a
lot like it's more like revenge to me
than anything constructive and so I
think that a lot of modern-day activism
has revenged deep inside it and the
Internet
the Internet has a way of looking after
that you know it kind of internet
selects for emotion and revenge is a
deep deep deep deep emotion so I think
that is echoing through through our
current situation more and more and I
guess that's why the Atlantic was picked
it up because it's it's become more
relevant not less relevant over the
years yeah it has and you mentioned that
one of the things you realize is the way
we talk about race and racism and all of
the discrimination all of these things
particularly in the age of social media
isn't actually constructive we're not
trying to get to a better place would
that be fair to say I think we're trying
but it's but it's not a good method so
so what I see from these these
disciplines these kind of fundamentalist
sect of the new Left I mean I've been
talking about it I think as polite
society we all agree that racism sexism
homophobia that they're bad things but
we don't agree on how to remedy them and
I think that in the past liberal ethics
or treating everyone the same was
something that was delivering gains on
those fronts unless civil right look
culturally and socially I think a lot of
people became a lot more accepting
because of liberal ethics Universal
liberal ethics and so this new
postmodern ethic that these people have
is a completely different remedy for the
problem and I don't think it's gonna
work I think it'll make things much
worse and so the way the way I look at
it is is that if racism and sexism
homophobia is a flu and we're looking at
a patient and we're both like well
there's something wrong here right we
don't we want to fix this this is a
pathology let's get in there these post
modernists are saying chemotherapy let's
just give a chemotherapy that was level
sorted and then the rest of us are like
bed rest maybe some antibiotics let's
calm down but
like let's just throw everything out
this thing and I don't think it's
constructive or it's gonna kill the
patient and secretly when you actually
look at what they they're on about they
want some kind of total revolution so
they secretly do want to kill the
patient because the afterlife is the
left-wing utopia the thing that they
want to take it's like you say that
might as you say most people won't be
familiar with that so what's your
evidence for that what's your evidence
for them wanting to to you know
overthrow society or whatever they're
very explicit and so you can just go to
I think James Lindsay has has a great
resource on this new discourses so he's
he James Helen Peter Boghossian were the
subjects of my new film but I didn't
want to take what they were saying on
face value I didn't want to be like a
glorified cameraman that was just like
recording what I was saying and
delivering that to the people I wanted
to figure out what the hell was going on
myself
does that ain't rest' and so over the
course of the last few years we've kind
of morphed into this weird startup think
tank where we're mapping the landscape
and trying to figure out what the hell's
going on here nothing happens
disciplined from the outside and where
they come from what's the intellectual
history behind it and James is starting
to run out creating a platform new
discourses and it's is aggregating all
the all the proof that you've you were
talking about what proof do you have
so it's in the literature it's all
through the literature it's I've spent a
lot a lot of time reading this stuff and
I can I mean I can email your stuff we
can we can sort it out but it's it's
there and they're quite explicit about
this so what is it that they want
exactly a revolution they couldn't
change everything but it's strange
because you've got it's almost like
their work foot soldiers that don't know
who the generals are so if you go back
further in time you real that they're
talking about totally their their
disaffected Marxists I guess then they
want to new they want a new way to Jimmy
up the population into creating the new
Marxist utopia and so
they change the way than you left
changed the way that that would take
place yeah and so and so then you've got
then you've got generations upon
generations that are kind of moving
along with with this way of thinking and
expanding upon it and then moving into
further further details and smaller
smaller papers smaller arguments and all
of a sudden you've got you've got this
whole entity that's actually it starts
in this strange revolutionary enterprise
but if you're reading the today's paper
and you're in your hands it's about corn
bread being racist or something like
that
it's it doesn't it's hard to figure out
what the enterprise is when you look at
the the surface level argument the we're
swimming in now we're swimming in these
surface level arguments we are swimming
in the mean level of this thing where if
you look underneath it and you go
further and further down there is a
revolutionary philosophy underneath it
and why do you think it's resonated so
so much especially with these current
generation because look there must be a
reason is it a dissatisfaction is it the
fact that capitalism isn't working for
young people why do you think it's
resonating so strongly Mike there's a
lot there's a lot to go into like we can
look at it from a philosophical angle we
can look at it from a an economic angle
like things are harder to it's harder to
advanced now we can look at it from an
overproduction of elites that are
they're trying to find new ways to
advance within our our our centers of
cultural production you can look at it
from a moral perspective that where God
is dead and we're all dealing with the
existential weight of not having a
plausible external source for morality
and so any any external doctrine for
morality will the market value of that
will go right up in a time like that
like you meet people who are distortions
it's like I'm I'm I'm bribe grabbing on
to these one moral thing and that will
define me that's like my the one thing
that I can I can grab on to
and so you see all these these doctrines
popping up which are moral communities
saying hey look you can you don't need
that existential way of creating your
own moral system we have a moral system
over here and I think there's something
to do with I sound like a madman I know
but if you're the more of the philosophy
you dig into the more you you realize
that this and there's some strange big
tectonic shifts taking place in our
culture right now what is really thing
in particular that you could pinpoint or
any of these big tectonic shifts that
you'd be able to explain to our audience
who might not be aware of it that's why
I want to make films I can go and make
films and be a weird guy and then just
drop it and people can understand it's
good it explains it in a different way I
don't think I don't know how to
articulate some of these things but it's
I mean people it's just moral
communities modern moral communities
that are evangelizing and people want to
become part of a moral community it's
it's a dearth of religion it's a
spiritual problem that we've got and so
people are trying to solve it and
they're trying to solve it these certain
people are trying to solve it
politically and do you think this well
it taps into our latent narcissism as
well especially the virtue signaling
especially the online activism and it's
a narcissism that we all have like when
you created your video part of it was
like you talked about that when in the
film you saw the guy walking away and
that made you feel angry that in a sense
you've got away of his crime but also
part of it and let's be fair I share
this as well as like I want to make my
video go viral yeah exactly yeah yeah
yeah well there's a level of if you have
moral standing you have like a divinity
role in your moral community and so that
that's a status and so I'm also part of
building if you look at letter dot wiki
I'm building social media networks and
if you behind the scenes of what social
media actually is it's its status as a
service so it's people are using social
media and we cheer to a point where
people are kind of using social me
in order to ratchet up their status and
so when you've got this kind of moral
system that's got its own language and
it's ready to go and its zeitgeist
friendly then that's a resource for for
ratcheting up your divinity factor
within your moral community and so
there's a lot of people who I mean look
at the Instagram models kind of go on
black lives matter and they're like
taking all these photos of themselves at
rallies and things like that this is
part of that that is it is about
creating some kind of moral standing
within within the community so this is I
mean the cynical ways to look at it
there's there's there's this there's
kind of people searching for answers
ways to look at it there's economic ways
to look at it where does in this kind of
Malstrom have changed and it's I mean
it's fascinating but also scary it is
and by the way Francis has never had a
video go viral so here's what we're
gonna do Mike next time he is being
racist I'm gonna record it I'm gonna
send you the footage and we're gonna
make a little film you want to do I've
got I've got the face I've got the
wardrobe and most importantly I've got
the voice so perfect but this is a
question that we that we always ask
people but I'm really be interested to
get your opinion on it all all political
movements inevitably burn themselves out
there they have their peaks and then
they sort of fizzle out do you think
we're at close to it fizzling out or do
you think it's just continuing to it's
gonna continue to get stronger well from
what I've been looking at is there's
it's a billion-dollar industry there's
bricks and mortars there's a doctrine
that's been sitting there for 30 years
it's been built upon and so it's not
it's not I can't see it going anywhere
it's these people have careers and jobs
built around this stuff there is a lot
of these kind of nonprofit organizations
popping up with this doctrine underneath
it and so you do doesn't it doesn't go
away we
we have to develop tools to live with it
and to understand it I think well that's
because my mob to this point I think our
position is very very much this stuff is
nonsense we've got to fight it and
defeat it but you think it's no it's new
it I'd be very surprised if it if it
disappears
you know it'll continue on in some sense
I think it's probably enterprise that
Jim and I getting into this we can
potentially draw lines around part of it
like I don't know we're talking about
this huge phenomenon but we're looking
at this kind of fundamentalist new left
SEC set which I think is the dangerous
part of it right this there's all sorts
of culturally woke people with this then
there's the clergy and so we look at
that and you can draw lines around it
and actually talk about it as some kind
of religious entity then maybe it will
get ratcheted down and we can apply
separation of church and state
principles to it but I don't know I
don't imagine I don't know it's funny
yes that we're living in a time like
that um ooh
strange times call for God solutions I
guess it's you've got to do something I
can't imagine it disappearing it's it
would be very strange because this
hasn't been I mean I know it's gonna
sound incredibly stupid and naive now
that I'm saying it out loud but that is
how stupid and naive I am I've been
sitting there for the last few years
going look look at this new thing that
they're saying that's really obviously
stupid more people are going to realize
that this stuff is nonsense now and then
look at this other thing you know
they're banning sombreros from from
university parties you know they only go
there now they've now they banned
clapping at some universities because
it's triggering and it's a
microaggression
now they're doing this now they're doing
that not in you know and and I was
thinking well like eventually all of
that is going to stack up to a point
where enough people are gonna go this is
[ __ ] you know let's wake up let's
stop this but but it's not happening no
it's not just some thing that popped out
of nowhere it's good it's it's it's got
decades of academic work underneath it
it's it's a it's a sophisticated
worldview and I mean we can laugh at it
we can we can poke at it and give it
[ __ ] because it is kind of crazy and
weird but it's it's it's also
sophisticated they view the world in a
different way and the more you realize
what the way they view their work the
way they view the world you realize how
different it is from the way that you
view the world it's like hold on a sec
we're we're gonna have I think you
realize how deep that the the schism
actually is it's not political anymore
its philosophical it's some we're
heading into a new strange territory I
think and Mike this has been frequently
described as the culture war and if it
is a war and who is winning is it that
side it's winning was it the other side
well I would find it very difficult if
if this phenomenon is not as widespread
spread as I think it is I would find it
very difficult to gauge that because
I've been looking at it for several
years now and obviously we're kind of
hooked up in some kind of network and so
all my algorithms are bent toward it and
because I've started speaking publicly
about it all my inbox is full of people
with stories about how it's entering
their workplaces and how they feel
totally are alienated by certain groups
they have meeting groups and things like
that it's coming it's coming in to serve
all these areas of the world and I just
get a constant influx of people going
can you help me help me out I don't know
what's happening here and I'm concerned
about it so if my world view is just
flooded with this so it looks it looks
huge so if it wasn't as big as I think
it is then I'm kind of stuck in this
little bubble that I can't get out of
but I do I will put my hat in the ring
and say this is quite large this is I
think there's enough evidence to suggest
that
there is there is something afoot so I
don't I don't see it in view in terms of
winning and losing I don't I don't it's
not exactly how I look at it yeah well
my I know that you feel like you know
your primary way of expressing what you
feel and you think is through making
films but actually I have to say I think
this interview has been really really
insightful and helpful for us
and for a lot of our viewers and
listeners as well because you've really
narrowed it down to to what it is you
know you'd like you said these people
want a revolution it's based on 30 years
of academia and yeah but maybe you
started getting harder in 30 yeah yeah
yeah they started getting serious up to
30 years exactly and it's not going away
and we're all gonna have to find some
way of dealing with it and I think it's
been it's been really really great to
have you on so before we ask our last
question which I really I'm keen to hear
your answer to just tell everybody where
can they they find someone who work on
these issues where can they watch you
know your primary way of expressing
yourself which is of course your phones
yes check me out on on Twitter and then
YouTube there's Mike Nana na y na I want
to spend more time on YouTube but I'm
behind the scenes I'm obviously
researching this stuff with the guys and
I'm working on a feature-length film
that I want to release through other
distribution networks you know channel
so I can kind of break the bubble the
we're kind of stuck in so hopefully I
can throw it out and get a Netflix or
something like that who knows yeah the
way things are going right now what's
that sorry yeah it's gonna be I'll have
to Trojan horse it or something I have
to do something in order to get that in
but anyway so I'm gonna put more time
into the YouTube now as soon as I can
find time and so subscribe to that and
wait isn't that big some more stuff
brilliant well we'll put all the links
to the to the video digital antics
absolutely fantastic genuinely enjoyable
and the last question we always finish
with is what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society might that we
really should be well I was just
thinking for how much my inbox is full
of people who are having trouble with
this stuff and who feel alienated and
they're not speaking up so there I think
that there is this sense that public
conversation and private conversation
are two very different things even
public persona and private persona are
two very different things and so I don't
I don't I don't distinguish between the
two and so I get myself into a lot of
trouble by bringing my private was open
it to the public it's probably some kind
of disability but um I think that if we
can if we can just talk more but like
you talk the way you're talking at home
in your workplace and then and and stop
being so afraid just to say what you
think I think of that if we can have
more conversations around that so people
feel empowered just to be themselves I
think that's that's something the
fantastic it's a really really important
point because the more we silence our
thoughts and more we don't engage the
more we don't share ideas the bigger
this problem will be and the more it
will embolden a very very angry minority
who want to in your words and I believe
it as well start a revolution and for
those of you have never experienced one
they're not fun so thank you very much
for coming online it depends what you
like me it's a person we like if you
like killing people and chaos and and
all of that that quite fun for you so
there is a section of population that
would like that and a lot of people
don't think that they don't exist today
they really do but met a few of them and
I don't want that I don't want that guy
in charge that guys that's that's not
the guy you want looking after things or
Mike thank you so much for coming on
make sure you head over to Twitter
follow Mikey he put some some great
stuff and of course check out his work
and the movie we were talking about his
digital aunty but he's also got a range
of other things and we look forward to
the future film Mike men thank you so
much for coming on
well thanks for having me man who's good
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the YouTube channel click
the bell button the next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out and follow us on all the
social media at trigger pod and also
leave us a nice review on iTunes and
spread the word